فلسطينيه استشهد شاب برصاصه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مخيم الدهيشه للاجئين في
مدينه بيت لحم وقالت وزاره الصحه
استشهد نتيجه اصابته برصاص الحي في الصدر
خلال مواجهات
لاقتحام قوه الاحتلال المخيم فجر اليوم
من اطراف المخيم بعد اعتقال الاسير المحرر
يحيى السعدي نجد القيادي البارز في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي بسام السعدي اعتقاله
منزله غرب المخيم
دارت بين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال خلال
محاولاتها اقتحام المخيم دون اصابه
احم
لو قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طلب لينكن
ان الولايات المتحده تدين اعمال العنف
التي تستهدف المدنيين في اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه
في اعمال العنف من الجانبين يجب اي يواجه
عداله متساويه
[موسيقى]
ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك اي مبرر لها مطلقا
ويجب محاسبه كل من يتورث فيها وكما قال
الرئيس ايضا سندينه ايضا اولئك الذين
يفشلون في ادانه مثل هذه الهجمات والاسوء
من ذلك الذين يمتدحون او يكافئون
الارهابيين وعائلاتهم اننا قلقون لان هذا
العام شاهد مستويات اعلى بشكل كبير من
العنف في الضفه الغربيه من قبل
الفلسطينيين هو المستوطنين الاسرائيليين
على حد سواء هذا العنف يجب ان يتوقف
ومرتكبوه يجب ان يواجه عداله متساويه
هو بشان الاستيطان قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بلاده تدين النشاط الاستيطانيه
الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
السلام بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
اضفنا بلادهم مستمره في دعم حلل الدولتين
[موسيقى]
بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال للحصر التحرك
الاستيطاني نحو ضمن الضفه الغربيه وتعطير
الوضع التاريخي الراهن في الاماكن المقدسه
وعمليات الاخلاء والهدم والتحرير